en sortant de prison vous êtes accroché
au crack non
bonsoir
Coolio success mondial avec gangsta
Paradise
mondial avec gangsta Paradise et depuis
plus rien 2 millions et demi d'albums
vendus énormes énormes gros gros succès
quand ça Paradise Coolio pour vous et
c'était une belle revanche sur la vie
parce que c'est vrai que vous êtes né à
kompton qui est quand même le quartier
le plus le plus chaud de de Los Angeles
non quartier ravagé par la par la
violence par le crack un des quartiers
à l'âge de à l'âge de 17 ans
je suis allé dans un centre interne et
on peut pas
avant les 18 ans quand on a 17 ans on va
en prison si c'est vraiment terrible ce
qu'on a fait ce que j'ai fait c'était
pas si terrible mais c'était vraiment la
première fois
une fois c'est ne pas y retourner je n'y
retournerai plus
je parle pas de d'y être un ou deux
jours je parle de faire quelque chose de
faire un crime et ensuite rester
longtemps quand je suis sorti de prison
j'ai eu quelques problèmes par la suite
avec le crack il a fallu que je
travaille sur moi-même
et ensuite je me suis dédié totalement
au rap en sortant de prison vous êtes
accroché au crack non
c'était pas le crack
parce que la traque c'est une forme
chimique de la cocaïne ce n'est pas
vraiment c'est vraiment un produit
chimique
quand le crack est arrivé j'avais déjà
laissé tomber les dragues mais j'étais
ce qu'on appelle le rock cocaïne c'est
vraiment de la cocaïne en forme de
petites pierres c'est des free base quoi
mais c'est vrai que
acheter des lunettes ridicules
[Applaudissements]
ça m'est venu comme ça
c'est vrai qu'après l'histoire du free
base vous avez été obligé de vous
réhabiliter et de devenir pompier dans
le nord de la Californie
parce que je voulais être vraiment clean
je voulais faire quelque chose de Clean
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire donc
je suis allé débuter contre des
incendies
tu sais ce qu'il a fait pour sa
réhabilitation il a été des incendies
dans le nord de la Californie
que pensez-vous de Leslie alors
première chose
je veux pas apporter du jugement sur les
autres femmes en France mais c'est
vraiment la plus belle femme en France
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
c'est vraiment son visage ensuite elle
est sortie de la pièce
j'ai vu le reste
je dis waouh
vous savez comment ça se passe
quand on rencontre une femme spéciale
je suis marié depuis 20 ans et quand
j'ai vu ma femme c'est exactement pareil
je me suis approché d'elle et je lui ai
dit on va se marier et on va avoir des
enfants
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Leslie
comme chanteuse non sérieusement
elle est nouvelle
un peu d'entraînement de formation mais
maintenant je l'ai entendu en anglais
elle change elle chante mieux en
français
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
[Musique]
un pouce bleu